you know we suspected for a while that
when many of these right-wingers say
abortion is murder
they don't really mean that it's
something they say if it's convenient if
it helps them raise money now of course
some of them sincerely mean it and I
mean the voters but when you look at the
polls you see that uh support for
abortion being legal in most cases has
increased over the last 50 years quite
steadily and so intuitively there have
to be some shills out there who are only
claiming to have these positions about
abortion
to the extent that it's useful to them
politically but they don't really care
about it that much Donald Trump is a
really great example the Herschel Walker
Scandal as it's being called wherein
despite claiming to be pro-life despite
claiming that abortion is murder no
exceptions for rape incestor the life of
the mother despite saying all of those
things
he now has been credibly accused with
receipts of urging and paying one of his
ex-girlfriends uh to get an abortion
paying for one of his ex-girlfriends to
get an abortion so of course the
Republicans will now denounce Herschel
Walker right we cannot support a man who
no it's not happening it turns out
apparently they don't really care about
abortion being murder here's Dana losh
Lesh uh who says quite straightforwardly
she's a right-wing radio host I don't
care if Herschel Walker paid to abort
endangered baby eagles I want control of
the Senate so does this change anything
I I mean do you want my opinion are you
listening yeah not a damn thing oh
how many times have I said four very
important words
these four words winning is a virtue oh
what I'm about to say is in
no means a contradiction okay or a
compromise of a principle so in other
words it is that
and please keep in mind that I am
concerned about one thing and one thing
only at this point
so I don't care if Herschel Walker paid
to abort endangered baby eagles I want
control of the Senate right
if The Daily Beast story is true
you're telling me Walker used his money
to reportedly pay
some skank for an abortion and Warnock
wants to use all of our Monies to pay a
whole bunch of skanks for abortions
so the big takeaway here is a lot of
these people don't really think abortion
is murder or they do but they're willing
to vote for the murderers anyway if it's
politically convenient Republicans think
abortion is murder except when the
Senate is on the line here's Don Lemon
on CNN last night speaking to right wing
you know whatever right-wing strategist
right-wing analyst consultant Alice
Stewart
and uh this is just unbelievable there's
a whole position here because the entire
time that we've been on the air together
you said that the reason that you held
your nose and voted for Donald Trump was
because of his stance on abortion right
and now you're saying it doesn't matter
that that Herschel Walker is
hypocritical about an abortion and
allegedly has paid for one right an
abortion that it is now okay
because
of inflation so
listen guys abortion is murder but have
you seen these gas prices what I'm
saying right now if I were back in my
home state of Georgia and I had to
decide between a candidate like Herschel
Walker who may or may not have paid for
one abortion or Raphael Warnock who is
supportive of taxpayer-funded abortions
for everyone I think the the choice is
very simple Herschel Walker's policies
are more in line with Republicans and
conservatives in the state of Georgia
and moving forward this is going to be a
tremendous how do you know he's telling
you the truth about those issues if he's
not telling you the truth about abortion
we'll just have to take his word for it
like you took his word about the
abortion thing right uh wow wow and then
rounding this out is Newt Gingrich who
um talks about how Walkers deeply
committed to Christ and also has had
many concussions so I guess it's okay
what he did I don't know I talked to
Herschel about this this morning and
I've known her show a good while oh well
if you've known him for a long time then
certainly please proceed I think he's a
remarkable person I think he's the most
important Senate candidate in the
country because he'll do more to change
the Senate just by the sheer Presence by
his confidence by his deep commitment to
Christ right by the degree to which he
is you know he's been through a long
tough period he had a lot of concussions
coming out of football yeah listen you
can't blame the guy who says abortion is
murder for paying for an abortion he
could be concussed for all we know
that's Newt gingrich's take these people
are completely pathetic these people are
hypocrites these people so that I
tweeted about this and there's kind of
there's really two possibilities here
okay one they do believe abortion is
murder
they really do
they just don't care about voting for
so-called murderers as long as it keeps
a Democrat out of office that's one
possibility the second possibility is
they don't really believe abortion is
murder it's just something that they say
when it's convenient in order to raise
money and it is becoming extremely
obvious the more that this Herschel
Walker thing goes let's now talk about
the polling in that race so I have new
polling from the Herschel Walker Raphael
Warnock race but what I want to make
sure everybody knows
is that this polling is from before the
abortion Scandal okay so it's we don't
yet know the effect of the abortion
Scandal but there is some good news
based on new polling there's a Fox News
poll that now is part of the mix and I
know people say Fox News Fox News
polling is actually fine it's a totally
fine pollster on average
Raphael Warnock is now ahead of Herschel
Walker by 1.3 points now again important
caveats all of this polling is from
before the abortion Scandal and I'm
calling it that I don't believe abortion
is a scandal but it's the abortion
Scandal meaning Herschel Walker for a
year campaigning on abortion is the
absolute worst thing in the world now
credibly accused of having paid for a
woman's abortion after urging her to get
that abortion so the polling is from
before that Scandal we don't know yet
how that Scandal will affect the polling
and number two this is too tiny a lead
to really Bank on right so up until a
few days ago Walker was up by like under
one point now Warnock is up by a little
over a point this is all way too small a
lead to assume anything one way or the
other everyone must vote I hope that
you're registered uh in Georgia and uh I
hope that you plan to vote because this
is you know we talk about what are the
most important Senate races on which uh
this election could could hinge control
of the Senate could hinge Pennsylvania
is at the top of the list but Georgia is
close as well 538 has one of these
um sort of uh I don't know what we call
it forecasts for I think they they call
it they are calling the Georgia Senate
election a toss-up but it is swinging
more and more in warnock's favor
yesterday they had it at a 54 chance
that Warnock wins now 538 has it at a 50
five percent chance that Warnock wins
now that's that's basically a coin flip
right if you've got to flip a hundred
coins
and one guy wins 55 and the other you
know it's heads 55 times and Tails 45.
that's very very close to a toss-up and
as you can see there has been a little
bit of a bump recently for Warnock but
really not much so we'll see what the
um effect of the abortion Scandal is but
don't think for a second that's staying
home in this one is a good idea because
control of the Senate could hinge on it
let's hope that Warnock grabs a couple
of points uh thanks to this abortion
related Herschel Walker Scandal all
right what just one more one more
Herschel Walker clip for today it's
totally unrelated to the abortion
Scandal I just want to let you all know
that Herschel Walker has now jumped on
uh the electric vehicle tirades I think
is what we're calling them Marjorie
Taylor green has been blasting electric
vehicles while understanding very little
about it uh Trump has been attacking
electric vehicles to some degree here is
Herschel Walker visibly confused about
electric vehicles what they are how they
work and this is now a theme among
Republicans they're very very angry
about something they don't really
understand you know you're talking about
an electric car right solar panels it's
like right now solar panels I want to
afford grocery I want to afford eggs and
milk you're talking about me getting
solar panels you got me a tax credit to
buy electric car that's cost more than
my house so I'm gonna put the solar pan
on my roof for my house on the roof of
my car oh and that's what I'm living in
I said let's get down to the true facts
the true facts are
this is not the new normal for right
this this is definitely not I hope that
the candidates like Herschel Walker are
not the new normal now oftentimes I'll
look online at different you know uh
discussions
um about electric vehicles and
um the exact same stuff that Herschel
Walker is saying here it's all confused
it's gobbledygook it doesn't make any
sense it's the same stuff that many of
the anti-electric vehicle people say in
their online forums they're tapping out
these angry messages furiously
it's the exact same stuff that many of
the anti-electric vehicle people uh
email me about okay it might not hurt
him at all in the polls because a lot of
the people already supporting him
believe all the same stuff that he's
saying oh they want to force these
expensive vehicles on us you've got to
take it Point by point on price the mini
SC electric and the Nissan Leaf are
under thirty thousand dollars the Chevy
bolt and the Mazda mx-30 are just over
thirty thousand dollars as new vehicles
use they are even less you will save on
gas so some of the costs now
is made up for later as you don't have
to pay for the gas that they say is so
overpriced and expensive in terms of the
cars cost more than houses
I'm aware of houses in some parts of the
country
that are like 30 grand I I I I've
recently became aware that there are
thirty thousand dollar houses but
Herschel Walker has a multi-million
dollar mansion and so the electric
vehicles are definitely not more than
his house that's for sure now there are
real problems with electric vehicles to
be solved There's real problems with
internal combustion engine Vehicles as
well we could be working on solving the
problems with electric vehicles rather
than dealing with these very silly and
uninformed attacks well there's not
enough charging stations right well Joe
Biden's trying to work on that and just
put forward a bunch of money in the
infrastructure Bill to build more
charging stations electric vehicles
don't fix the issue
of just too many individual people
driving around in cars we would be much
better off with maybe uh more work from
home combined with better funding public
transit and you just get cars off the
road great and electric vehicles better
than an internal combustion engine but
it would be better for that person not
to be driving around in an individual
vehicle anyway well but Republicans are
against funding public transit the
material intensity and the waste and the
need for so-called conflict minerals for
electric vehicles and batteries what do
we do with the batteries after their
useful life is over there are real
issues here like with just about
anything that exists uh on our planet
they will improve with time but they
will improve much more quickly If
instead of fighting idiotic statements
about electric vehicles like the ones
we've heard from Herschel Walker and
Marjorie Taylor green and others if we
would actually spend time dealing with
the problems better than internal
combustion engine of course
can it improve even further yes but
these Republicans are actively trying to
sabotage it they really are horrible all
of the clips I've played for you in
these first three segments you can watch
them on our Instagram at davidpackman
show and you can react let me know what
you think about the anti-ev nonsense by
finding me on Twitter at dpacman
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
all right some extraordinarily explosive
new allegations that have surfaced in
the last 24 hours regarding the former
guy that guy the orange Menace mango
Mussolini whatever right you know the
guy I'm talking about the first is that
failed former president Donald Trump
asked his lawyer to lie to the
government for him and this is just an
unbelievable story best Levin from
Vanity Fair reporting surprise Trump a
pathological liar reportedly asked his
lawyer to lie to the government about
his classified document cash the
ex-president wanted his lawyer to say
he'd returned everything in February
which was obviously not the case this
relates directly to the other Trump
lawyer Christina Bob who eventually did
make the claim that everything was
returned it was a lie and as I told you
on I believe Monday she has now lawyered
up Maga making attorneys get attorneys
best Levin writes in in uh quoting The
Washington Post The Washington Post
reports that in early 22
the ex-president asked Alex Cannon an
attorney who'd work for both the Trump
organization and the Trump campaign to
tell the National Archives and Records
Administration that all materials
requested by the agency had been turned
over despite the fact that Trump was
still in possession of thousands more
government documents now another thing
we learned yesterday is Trump personally
packed a bunch of those documents but we
will get to that but the point is Trump
knew the documents hadn't been returned
because he had them okay according to
the post Canon who had quote facilitated
the January transfer of 15 boxes of
presidential records from Mar-A-Lago to
the National Archives after archives
officials agitated for more than a year
to get all original presidential records
did not feel comfortable making such a
claim in other words it was a lie
he reportedly told people he didn't know
if all the requested material had been
returned and quote other Trump advisors
also encouraged Canon not to make such a
definitive statement did Canon hesitate
because he was aware of the fact Trump
had a long history of lying about
everything all the time who is to say
Canon didn't respond to the post's
request for a comment so think about how
absurd this story has gotten we still
don't really know the motive for why
Donald Trump kept these top secret and
other documents we don't know where the
ones that are still missing to this day
went that's another story there's a
dozen layers to this we have the picture
of the folders for top secret and
otherwise restricted documents which
were empty when the FBI found them
obviously Donald Trump didn't take empty
folders meaning the documents are
somewhere and we don't know where are
they at Bedminster another one of Donald
Trump's clubs golf clubs whatever you
want to call them we don't know we but
the point is not only do we not know the
whereabouts of some of those documents
we still don't really know the motive
for taking them because the stories
we've been told don't make any sense
Trump wanted it for his Library he never
talks about his Library he doesn't care
about his Library Trump wanted them to
read Trump doesn't read Trump wanted
them in order to write his Memoirs Trump
doesn't write there's no
plausible innocent reason
why he would want those and then you get
into the not so innocent reasons which
include selling them or whatever the
case may be the other aspect to this is
that remember the justice department
thought the situation was serious enough
to conduct a search warrant at
Mar-A-Lago now this isn't a criticism of
that decision this is just a reminder
that if the justice department felt this
was that serious
there may have been reason they believed
something was about to happen with these
documents if the impetus for the search
warrant was less about were imminently
charging Trump but more about we have
reason to believe he's about to do
something with these documents then that
would be a whole other area of
exploration but then there's Trump
wanted his lawyer to lie
Trump knew the documents hadn't been
returned
and he instructed his lawyer to lie his
lawyer didn't do it Alex Cannon
eventually Christina Bob another lawyer
was willing to make that claim on paper
and she has now obtained a lawyer and is
willing to cooperate with the Department
of Justice and she herself is facing
possible legal trouble and then the next
part of this is something else we
learned yesterday Trump personally
packed a stash of documents to take to
his house
um this next story
makes yesterday's clip from the
interview that Donald Trump did with
Maggie Haberman even more extreme and
we're going to get to that in a moment
Donald Trump is now reported to have
personally packed a stash of documents
returned from Mar-A-Lago and he kept
hundreds more until the FBI sees them
remember all these questions about oh
did Trump know did Trump do it himself
of course not of course not the new
report per the Washington Post is that
Donald Trump personally packed 15 boxes
of material returned to Nara in January
he trialed but tried but failed to get a
lawyer to claim that was all he had
that's the previous story about Alex
Cannon many secret and classified
records were later found in an August
FBI raid at Mar-A-Lago remember that
yesterday we played a clip for you which
I'm going to play again right now as a
reminder of Donald Trump it's a
recording of Donald Trump talking to the
New York of the New York Times Maggie
Haberman where the question of documents
came up lo and behold it turns out Trump
was lying nation that you had with
Donald Trump where you brought up
the correspondence he had with North
Korean leader Kim Jong-un New York Times
released audio of this now we have audio
of this conversation so let's listen
did you leave
with anything in particular are there
any Memento documents you took with you
anything nothing of great
urgency okay I have great things there
you know uh
the letters the Kim Jong-un letters I
had many of them you were able to take
those with you look at what's happening
wow no I think that has the I think
that's in the
archives but most of it is in the earth
okay Trump knew when he made that claim
that he had taken a bunch of stuff and
the report now is he did it in himself
he did it himself and this puts an
entire new light on this entire story
took him himself allegedly
told his lawyer to lie about it and this
is the pattern looking for someone else
to take the fall now Alex Cannon made
the right decision made the right
decision to not sign off and say
everything's been returned he suspected
seemingly that Donald Trump was full of
you know what Christina Bob then signed
off on the documents swearing we did a
sweep we know it's all gone from
Mar-A-Lago we don't have any more
documents now she has had to hire a
lawyer and this Last Detail because
remember all along at the end of the day
whether the documents were planted or
whether they were there or whatever
Eric Trump and others insisted Trump
doesn't personally pack he's a
billionaire he's the president he's not
personally stuffing documents into a box
the new report from The Washington Post
is that that is exactly what Donald
Trump did
and it certainly removes any Specter of
plausible deniability let's now see what
the latest claim is from Trump himself
Donald Trump gave a very strange
interview to a guy named Joe Pags I
don't know who Joe Pags is but he really
likes Trump and during this interview
Donald Trump went back to the story of
the FBI might have planted the documents
to frame me or they might have stolen
documents wait the FBI planted or they
stole they brought in or they took out
and if that's the case how did you know
to telepathically declassify the very
documents that the FBI planted none of
it makes any sense but Trump is back on
this train once again and they wouldn't
let us have lawyers there they wouldn't
let us have any representation so who
knows what was planted who knows what
was put in there who knows what was
taken out and you know if you look at
the group it's a largely radical left
run narrow right and you look at it it's
all EX they're quite frankly Communists
folks this was generally speaking a
really wild interview Trump is doing
very minor shows by phone not even
taking the time to get in front of a
video camera that's the theme
desperation to be interviewed anywhere
that will have them he's welcome on this
program Anytime by the way let's listen
to a little bit more of this Joe Pags
interview and you'll notice it's not
exactly hard hitting
you're beyond very good so I was a
television news anchor in Michigan for
eight years I I was on the streets as a
reporter I know that's made very well
they love you there and I'll never
forget what you did in 2016 at about
three o'clock in the morning in Grand
Rapids and about 5 000 people showed up
to cheer you on as you wanted to beat
Hillary Clinton why is Michigan so
important to you yes
tough question by the way
to the state I was given the man of the
year award Joe years ago like that's a
lie
that's a lie first question first answer
that's a lie this is old ground Trump
has repeatedly claimed that he won
Michigan's Man of the Year award the
award does not exist
seven seconds in
Trump has already told a lie eleven or
twelve years ago and I used to tell them
why are you countries like Mexico to
take your cars your automobile
manufacturing business away and I don't
know I've always felt that Michigan just
let so much get away it's got such
assets that it just let so much go away
I mean it anyway so it's just lies and
lies and lies let's just jump you know
randomly into the middle of the
interview just to get a little bit more
of the flavor Mr President the only time
we found out anything that may or may
not have been at Mar-A-Lago was after
they took it and started leaking it out
so what do you think the game is here
yeah
you know what Jesus hard-hitting no like
why did you have the documents that is
very interesting nobody ever heard any
leaks or anything any problems and then
all of a sudden when they take it out
and they put it into Nara or wherever
they have it all of a sudden things
started leaking out so documents started
it's all leaking everywhere so a very
strange interview riddled with lies as
usual and the theme is
nobody's even having Trump on in terms
of the serious networks it's Joe Pags
and real America's voice and right side
broadcasting wild times and just imagine
what's going to happen over the next
week as all of these different legal
issues come to a head we'll take a quick
break and be back with Jesse singer
right after this
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show today I'm
going to be speaking with Jesse singer
who is a journalist and also author of
the book there are no accidents the
deadly rise of injury and disaster who
profits and paid and who pays the price
uh Jesse great to have you on I really
appreciate it thank you so much for
having me David so you know in the
context of these uh I'll start with
something kind of micro and then we'll
go from there there's often these
stories of oh there was an accident with
a gun someone was shot it was an
accident a guy accidentally shot his
daughter while cleaning the gun or
something like this and we often will
talk about on the show where okay yes we
sort of understand socially what the
term accident means under the law this
is often called the negligent discharge
of a firearm and sometimes it is
something that people are charged with
and it's considered a crime at least in
theory but the term accident sometimes
puts like a very particular spin as it
may be on our understanding of sort of
like what happened you talk about this
at the corporate and the industrial and
and other levels talk a little bit about
what does it mean for something to be an
accident in the context of law and our
understanding of what took place to just
kind of get us into the discussion
yeah I mean I mean it's a really tricky
term in that sense because it you know
it
in so many different things
thankful and then has this specific
legal definition of the line between
intentional violence
um and maybe an act of God you know
someone who dies during a hurricane for
example totally out of our control and
it is a way of I found in the book
absolving certain people when things go
wrong and punishing others you know and
so we see
um really different outcomes depending
on who's shot in the case of an
accidental discharge you know who the
victim is
um and whose gun it was
um and whether or not we want to put
blame on them as a society and this even
breaks down to the smallest levels like
if you look at
people being killed by drivers in like
jaywalking crashes yes
um um or like drunk drunk driving
crashes in particular where someone's
you know struck by a driver the race of
the victim correlates with sentence
length so that if the person struck by a
drunk crossing the street by a drunk
driver is is black the sentence length
of the driver is significantly lower so
there isn't an area of accidental
so-called accidental death where you
know we're not seeing huge variations in
how the term is understood to
um
to you know kind of equate for different
punishments and then since so many of
these things are not individual acts of
human error but really predictable
preventable systemic causes we see the
least culpability when it comes to the
actual like corporate perpetrators of
these crimes you know and like how
the make and model of a gun and the
design of a gun and the way that the gun
has not been regulated is actually the
real problem here rather than whether or
not it went off when you were cleaning
it you know there's this book I read a
few months ago I think it's it must be
about 20 years old now it's called
normal accidents by a guy named Charles
perro I think is the pronunciation of
his last name and in the book he talks
about a lot of different areas he talks
about aircraft accidents he talks about
nuclear he all these different areas and
he kind of distinguishes what we might
call like systemic accidents which are
in a sense predictable where we might
say here is a system here are the
tolerances here are the ways the system
can fail and we can sort of make a
prediction as to how common these things
will be and it's not going to be zero
almost certainly it's not going to be
zero and one of the really interesting
things he writes about in the book is
that as you add mechanisms to try to
make a system them more safe the added
complexity and the fact that you now
have systems interacting can actually
keep the odds of an accident so-called
roughly the same or sometimes even even
kind of increase them we know that to
some degree these accidents are
predictable in systems because actuaries
in Insurance part of their job is to
sort of like put a monetary value and a
number on How likely are some of these
things to happen on this on the issue of
predictability and preventable when it
comes to industrial type stuff
we often will learn after the fact that
industry knew about a lot of these risks
very specifically and they either
minimized it covered it up whatever the
case may be what are the kind of counter
pressures that the public can sort of
exert or the tools that exist not after
the fact to do a class action lawsuit or
a mass tort but in the lead-up to these
systems sometimes failing and what as
you write about also are predictable
ways
absolutely yeah pero's like kind of the
one of the classics of this field who
really like gave us a framework for
understanding and one of the things I
try to do in the book is take perro's
basic ideas this normal accident Theory
um and by which he didn't mean uh normal
as in uh common but but predictable yes
um the inevitable you know consequence
of our systems and he meant that an
accident is a thing that exists in four
walls a nuclear power plant an oil
tanker this contained thing but
something I try and do is blow out that
theory to look at the much larger
systems we have that correlate directly
to accidents and that's income
inequality that's racism that's
corporate power and a lack of Union
power
you know because we talk about these
things as random and if it was true you
know then an injury-related death would
be randomly distributed across the
country but it isn't true people of
color people living in poverty are most
at risk
um and what we see is that you know most
people who die in accidents don't die in
Charles parrow's accidents you know a
nuclear meltdown right now ones and twos
every day on our roads in our homes and
in our workplaces and so to answer like
what the solution is at the core of it
is that these accidents where people of
color and people living in poverty are
most at risk are accidents where policy
and infrastructure make the difference
between life and death so the safety of
our homes homes the safety of our roads
the safety of our workplaces and that's
where we see these huge disparities in
accidental deaths so to name one black
people die in house fires at twice the
rate of white people
indigenous people are struck by cars at
twice the rate of white people so these
aren't you know um you know matters of
individual error these are matters of
different conditions that different
people are facing whether or not your
apartment is a fire trap and whether or
not your government is regulating your
apartment and holding your landlord to
account and so the Big Picture answer is
that you know
regulating corporate power and forcing
policy to protect everyone universally
primarily through government regulation
and access to the social safety net will
reduce the way that risk is currently
unequally distributed across the U.S it
seems there's also sort of like a
psychological component like if we think
about drug overdoses as an example
recently at his rallies Donald Trump has
been too much praise from the audience
talking about we should do the death
penalty for drug dealers they do it in
China quick trial 100 conviction rate
you know all sorts of authoritarian
dystopian nightmares but the crowd loves
it and they cheer and there is something
about when there's an individual here's
the guy on the corner who gave me the
drugs versus here's a pharmaceutical
company that uses sales reps to
encourage the over prescription which
then you get from a doctor filled by a
pharmacist the personal blame seems much
easier psychologically when it's the guy
on the corner to some degree and that's
probably much to the Delight of the big
Pharma companies and their lobbyists
right like that's by that's a feature
for them
yeah absolutely and I think you often
see you know today from Pharma companies
um but throughout the history of
accidental death whenever there's a rise
in one specific type of accidental death
you see corporations pushing these bad
people stories right
um and so you know you see it directly
I'm going to quote um one of the Purdue
Pharma leaders you know who was like you
know the problem here early in the
opioid epidemic is the criminal addicts
the abusers they're the problem not how
we're marketing an addictive drug is
non-addictive but these individuals and
that is deeply comforting for us as
people we are comforted and feel
permitted to move on from what seems
like random tragedy when we can find a
bad guy because it's a way for us all to
say
I wouldn't make those decisions I'm not
like that person that that person who
died that person who hurt someone a
nothing like them because they're bad
and when we Define them as bad we can
see ourselves as good as as smarter as
someone who will do a little better
under the same circumstances and this
ranges from you know accidental death
where we really do see a stigmatized bad
person like a person who's addicted to
drugs yeah but also when you know on the
little ones like a traffic crash or you
know a fire where a kid was playing with
matches finding the bad person you know
blaming the parent blaming the
jaywalking pedestrian is a way for us
all to say it can't happen to me I'd
make better decisions
um and we see throughout the history of
accidental death even all the way back
to the Industrial Revolution you know
when workers were dying and Untold
numbers and factories and coal mines we
see industrialists pushing this idea of
the accident-prone worker and this
caricature and stereotype of a drunk
immigrant who doesn't speak English
sloppy worker that was really the cause
of this massive accidental death toll
and in fact it was actually that the
factories and the coal mines were
incredibly dangerous and we know this
because when we start to regulate those
factories and coal mines accidental
death on the job plummets yes so
speaking of that I mean I think it's not
at all a one it's an all of the above
for me not a one of these things we have
ways in which regulation uh can make
things safer whatever it is those things
we're talking about are there's also
those who say to different degrees
technology is going to dramatically
improve these things as we learn more
about how to design roads self-driving
cars you know you have all of these
ideas that at some point technology is
going to make a lot of things much safer
technology and factories that is going
to reduce injury for example the counter
to that seems to be that the new
technology allows the limits to be
pushed for profit again so like now you
have sort of like the same amount of
safety but there's more profit and more
productivity and so you have to know
kind of how to counterbalance that but
to what degree is it fair to believe
that technology will be a factor in
making the world safer
you know so this is this is an old Story
and there's always been huge advances in
technology that have reduced the
accidental death toll but only under one
condition which is when they are
regulated and so if you look at
technology like seat belts airbags
collapsible steering columns these were
in the car huge advances in safety but
only once they were regulated into every
American Automobile and when they're not
when you have government regulatory
agencies that are afraid to regulate
like Nitsa is today we get into a
situation where rich people survive and
poor people die
um so like fully autonomous driverless
cars are a way off but there's a wealth
of life-saving technology that already
exists is tested and proven automatic
emergency braking intelligent assist
speed Governors that are regulated in
other countries where accidental death
is far lower but we don't mandate them
here cars are under regulated so only
the rich are protected the rich pay for
features that could say ever save
everyone's life if the government forced
it you know and we see the same thing
you know as far back as the Industrial
Revolution you know there were
Technologies a few companies were
putting them forth but the overall death
rates weren't falling because the
government wasn't forcing corporations
to account and when that happened we saw
results
last thing I want to talk about
um inevitably one could imagine this uh
kind of caricature of the over-regulated
nanny state where we take everything you
and I are talking about to the absolute
extreme and you know science fiction
movies are made about it and it's all
very very scary and to some degree I'm
like sort of joking about it but also I
think even people who are in favor of a
stronger regulatory infrastructure would
concede that there there's some limit at
which we say well here are some choices
we simply allow people to make but we
want to limit the collateral damage that
might be associated with those choices
so it's really a choice that only
affects the person making the decision
how do we start to think about where on
the slider we sort of put that pin
between the idea of freedom and safety
or do you think that that is not even a
valid Spectrum for discussion
I think it is a notably
um uh new Spectrum to discussion that I
think we spend a little too much time on
and we're talking about more than 200
000 people every year in the US that are
dying completely preventable deaths and
those numbers are infinitely lower in
other wealthy countries the rate of
accidental death is so much higher here
because we have this rhetorical
conversation about freedom but when it
comes down to it I think the nanny state
is wonderful if you don't want to die in
early death I mean what's a nanny it's
someone that rich people pay to protect
their children from Death we should all
have that
uh Americans will respond to what our
leaders promote this country did not
start to reject the protections of the
benevolent government like on its own
it's a product of corporate propaganda
sold through the mouthpiece of
anti-government anti-regulatory
presidents and that's been happening for
decades I don't think Americans want to
die horrible painful early deaths in the
name of Freedom we just need politicians
brave enough to protect people and to
tell a better story than this
anti-government anti-regulatory
propaganda that we've been sold yeah
crying about a nanny State often is a
way
to kind of invalidate conversations
about just reasonable regulations that
that should exist it's sort of a way to
kind of clamp down on debates it's kind
of similar to
I'm offended I'm oh well okay the
conversation's over then I guess it's a
similar cudgel in a sense
yeah absolutely and it leaves us in this
place where people die
preventable death
s ones and twos and we all tell a story
about personal responsibility and the
fact that maybe they were bad people
even though they're simply protectable
we're not going to fix human error we're
not going to make people perfect but
there are so many ways we could protect
them from harm that we are disregarding
for a conversation about freedom in the
nanny State and the need for personal
responsibility Jesse last thing lowest
hanging fruit in terms of preventable
death that could be improved relatively
simply or easily we know what to do what
are the areas that people may or may not
know about where the numbers are high
and could be lowered dramatically
it's true in every area of accidental
death by simply empowering our
Regulatory Agencies so people are better
protected and Reviving the social safety
nets so people can afford to better
protect themselves you know not drive an
old car take the most dangerous job live
in a fire truck apartment
um and because accidental death is so
broad there are a million ways to do it
in your community you can advocate for
traffic calming and public transit
expansions because you're far less
likely to die or to kill someone if
you're riding the bus than you are if
you're in your own car you can fight for
safe injection sites and the free
distribution of naloxone which directly
dramatically reduces accidental overdose
deaths pushing for Ada accessibility
accessibility like ramps and grab bars
you know in your workplace and in your
apartment building is going to reduce
accidental death making sure fire safety
regulations are on the books and
enforced sprinklers self-closing doors
all this stuff it doesn't you know
reduce the likelihood hood of you making
a mistake or a kid playing with fire or
someone not being a distracted driver
just reduces the likelihood that it's
going to kill anyone it just protects
people
we have been talking with Jesse singer
who is a journalist and also author of
the book there are no accidents the
deadly rise of injury and disaster who
profits and who pays the price Jesse
really appreciate your time today thanks
so much for having me David
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
I've told you before that Secretary of
Transportation Pete budajege is really
really good when he appears on
right-wing media and when he's
responding to his right-wing critics
will Pete Buda judge decimated the
homophobic comment of Marjorie Taylor
Green from over the weekend let's start
with her comment now I you can check out
my live stream from over the weekend
from the Trump rally I saw Marjorie
Taylor green talks about Pete Buddha
judge without even seeing the clip I
assumed and I know that sometimes when
you assume you end up made a fool of but
I assumed that if Marjorie is talking
about Pete it's probably homophobic it
just just the odds are if you've got if
I had to bet I would say if Marjorie
Taylor green is talking about Pete
Buddha judge there's probably some
homophobic element to what she says and
indeed there was indeed there was here
is what Marjorie said about the
Secretary of Transportation more
American and then the Roar of a V8
engine under the hood of a Ford Mustang
or Chevy Camaro an incredible
feel of all that horsepower
but Democrats like Pete budage want to
emasculate the way we drive right right
of course the gay Secretary of
Transportation wants to emasculate the
way people drive now what does that mean
emasculate the way people drive
I don't know but it probably has
something to do with electric vehicles
right
pickles after
industry by the way many michigan-based
automakers are making electric vehicles
making that comment particularly stupid
um let's go now to Pete bootage's
response he appeared on Fox news with
Neil Cavuto he was asked about these
comments and his answer is pretty funny
you've been pushing for this you've been
very consistent with that but
representative Marjorie Taylor green uh
the Georgia Republican at a rally in
Michigan said this past weekend uh the
Mr budditez is trying to emasculate the
way we drive by as she goes on to
explain by supporting environmentally
friendly Transportation but what did you
think of her wording he's trying to make
everybody feminine by making us drive
really cool fast cars that you don't
need to gas up and can charge in your
driveway it's really really feminine of
him
I I literally don't even understand what
that means I mean my sense of manhood is
not connected to whether my vehicle is
fueled by gasoline or whether it's
fueled by electricity well maybe it
should be Pete this is a practical map
you offended by that so because even
people who you know share her politics
didn't share that view
it was a strange thing to say uh you
know to be honest there are other
members of Congress that I pay more
attention to when I'm thinking about uh
opinions that that really matter or
ideas that are going to be critical to
engage with I do think we need to zoom
out a little bit and I know people want
to make this ideological they want to
make it political we're talking about
something like electric vehicles we're
talking again about a very practical
matter which is Imagine taking the issue
of getting off of fossil fuels at least
at the tailpipe for the way we drive
around and thinking that the issue
really is about how the Secretary of
Transportation wants to emasculate
others
and implicit in that of course of course
is the fact that uh Pete Buddha judge is
is a gay man it's just unbelievable and
I know I've told the story before but
I'll remind you of it I've experienced
this there's something about the
electric cars that really triggers a lot
of these right Wingers and I've
described before
more than a couple dozen instances where
when I go anywhere and I park in the
parking lot you know a grocery store or
not a Starbucks of course not but you
know we're we're at places I really do
go I will often Park like in the
furthest spot from the front door and
I've always actually done this just
because I just walk more right I'll get
an extra walk I walk more to the front
door and then I walk more back to my car
but also I am kind of protective of my
electric vehicle and I don't want to
park near people and I like to keep it
far away and a couple dozen times I will
come out and there's one of these big
just gas guzzling Behemoth pickup trucks
with a thin blue line sticker and once
it was with a Confederate flag parked
right next to my car they're
intimidating me they're really
intimidating me and also just on the
road the pickup truck people uh with the
with the stickers the Trump stickers
whatever
at the at a green light when a red light
goes green just zooming off and leaving
leaving me in a cloud of black smoke
probably cost them costing them a dollar
in gas to for for that show of manhood
there's something wrong with these
people there really is and Marjorie
Taylor green talking about a V8 Camaro
and Mustang uh and electric vehicles
being emasculating is basically the
exact same thing will they ever come
around yeah I think eventually they will
because electric cars are clearly the
way things are going so I think
eventually they will come around and
some right Wingers have that uh that
that F-150 Lightning pickup truck
Electric
is selling pretty damn well I have to
say for those who were assuming that
Lauren bobert's re-election was a
foregone conclusion it may not be
it may not be we have some new polling
that shows it's not as bad as maybe it
seems axios reporting Lauren bobert's
re-election in Jeopardy according to a
new poll
uh by the numbers
bobert received support from 47 percent
of likely voters Democrat Adam Frisch
landed at 45. this makes the race a
statistical tie within the 4.4 plus or
minus percentage Point margin of error
seven percent of Voters are undecided
this is a survey from September 29 to
October 2nd taken by Keating research it
is a democratic firm but it is also one
of the most historically accurate
pollsters in Colorado this is a
five-point swing towards Frisch in July
it was bobert 4942
and this is a five point swing the a big
takeaway is that with bobert under 50 it
means she is vulnerable to losing the
race Frisch still has a lot of work to
do
but it is something now it's important
to understand as the axios article
points out the Third District in
Colorado overwhelmingly favors
Republicans and it is not actually
considered competitive by national
experts typically typically this is a
situation where the undecideds swing
towards the Republican in that District
538 has one of these forecasts it
currently has it at a
98 chance of bobert being reelected and
only a two percent chance of Adam Frisch
winning not a lot of polling in this one
it is worth voting if you live in the
Third District of Colorado I know we
have viewers in that area because you've
emailed me about this race vote do not
concede it costs you nothing to also
fill out the ballot
for member of Congress and if bobert
could be defeated it would be a major
victory for Democrats we will see we
will follow the race our voicemail
number is 2192 David P and you can call
that voicemail number anytime here is a
viewer who unfortunately like many of my
viewers and listeners is really confused
about my view of the democratic party
take a listen
I just want to know why you think the
Democrats are so great I mean but be
honest I don't care if you do or not at
least you heard this message
explained to me how the Democrats are so
great yeah higher gas prices
uh unemployment at an all-time high
I can keep naming us why I told the
borders come on man wake up yeah so
listen first of all almost nothing this
guy said is true open borders border
policy is almost completely unchanged
from Trump to Biden almost completely
unchanged record high unemployment we
have records low unemployment record low
unemployment mid threes we are
essentially at full employment
high gas prices gas prices are down
dramatically
uh and really they have very little to
do with the president of the United
States I didn't blame Trump when gas
prices went up and I didn't praise Trump
when gas prices went down I didn't blame
Biden when gas prices went up and I
didn't praise Biden when gas prices went
down it really doesn't have much to do
with the president at all but maybe the
most important confusion that this
caller has is I don't say the Democratic
party is so great
not even a Democrat again my view is
that the Democratic party is an
organization whose main goal is to
preserve its own existence preserve its
own existence I don't care about the
party at all to the extent that in any
particular race the better candidate is
a Democrat I'll vote for the Democrat
that's as far as my allegiance goes to
any political party and so this is not a
show where I say vote blue no matter who
or the Democratic party is great or
whatever the case may be this is a show
where I say I don't care about political
party I'm not a member of any political
party I evaluate candidates for their
policy and for their platforms and I
decide who closely or more closely
aligns with me sometimes it really is an
option of bad and less bad and I choose
the less bad option I think most
reasonable people would and sometimes
there are actual Democratic candidates
that I like and I I sort of willingly
and gladly vote for as well but uh
please criticize me for things I
actually say not things you imagine I
said we have a great bonus show for you
today we are going to talk about this
wacky Dr Oz story uh where experiments
research he was involved in reportedly
led to the deaths of more than 300 dogs
the story is a little more complicated
than the headlines make it out to be
which is why I'm glad to have the
opportunity on the bonus show to discuss
it California Democratic governor Gavin
Newsom who is a potential 2024 uh
presidential Contender has signed a bill
decriminalizing most jaywalking in
California who cares right jaywalking is
actually a tool that is used to
criminalize and to create a pretext for
interactions between police and citizens
and residents and uh it's actually a
really important bill we're going to
talk about why and the onion the
satirical publication defends its right
to to parody in a very real supreme
court brief relating to a satirist this
is also a re you know when these folks
on the right talk about free speech
um they really are talking about free
speech of a certain type
for certain people
they claim it's about all free speech
but it's really not this is a really
interesting case actually about Free
Speech all of those stories and more
coming up today on the bonus show thank
your lucky stars every day you're not
Dave Pacman well I have the pleasure of
hosting the bonus show every single day
you can sign up at joinpakman.com become
a member and we will see you on the
bonus show in just a moment otherwise
we'll be back tomorrow with a brand new
program
foreign